so it's already happening so if you
don't accept it we just going to be left
behind
I missed my flight from Detroit which
resulted in two extra plane rides and
editing my last film on the plane this
made my eyes so bloodshot from lack of
sleep they strip searched me for weed in
Tokyo when I arrived convinced I was
high I wasn't high welcome to the
busiest intersection in the world I'm in
Tokyo Japan if you're confused as to
what the seed envelope is that's totally
cool I pulled this global map which you
can find are not normal showed calm
where you plant a seed which is an
unfinished idea in your city each week I
choose a new scene I fly to that signal
and competed with you I pick each seed
weekly base for the creative fluid
States an impulsive worm of excitement I
click on the seed see which city you
from get in contact and fly to you
within a couple of days it's that simple
this week's seed is together we should
learn to love robots welcome to my new
weekly show not normal this brainy
secrets deflection not switch mystery to
say
we're gonna wipe out men of the godly
but some big tech and science names one
of a real life risk the loss of all that
we stop we take something because of
waste and media and some light research
on the plane I had this preconceived
unsettling feeling when taking my first
stroll through the streets of Tokyo like
I was being watched by a reflection of
humanity without emotions data was
constantly being monitored by a
civilization so advanced I couldn't even
fathom what the daughter
what's this really the case is Tokyo is
city fueled by some new dimension of
intelligence or would I be left feeling
totally ignorant of that diggity it's
time to meet the sweet cedar the basin
on top of the toilet oh yes yes it is is
that a normal thing yeah and you brush
your teeth in it it was at this moment
he knew I feel that my whole life has
been a lie I thought that Japan was
going to be noisy like I thought it was
gonna be a then I continue to explain my
illusion of Japan as a whole
Shin then suggestively takes the streets
again but this time with local insights
you took me through the dynamics of
Tokyo everything is indeed a lot more
electric and run smoothly than anywhere
else have been in the world but I've yet
to see these robots everyone's been
talking about
[Applause]
we sat down and chatted about why he
planted the seed so I tried to de-seed
of how welcomes all over into our world
because this whole a I'll evolutionary
thing is already happening the biggest
capital in the world is investing
billions and millions and money into the
utter shame telogen and accept it shen p
is a new-age thinker a trendy kid
aligned with the understanding robots
will advance our lives this is gonna be
a seriously tough concept to tackle one
that would need tons of research and
some deep contextualizing for you to
give you a bit of context before we
continue let's have a look at what's
being said on both sides of the picket
fence on one side robots represent the
threats of a jobless future that's in
the words of finis of African in unmask
robots we'll be able to do anything
better than us including the fear of
autonomous humanoid robots that Inhumans
lazy and conjugated ultimately wiping us
out altogether and taking control of the
world as we know it and on the other
there is an existence that war machine
revolutions always eliminate certain
jobs and change life as we know it they
rise suppurative it's creating new
better jobs and future life arguing that
we should embrace mechanical advances as
a means to advance human life
Bill Gates when visiting the lab of
Harvard said that the inventions he saw
challenged our popular images Terminator
style robots that robotic discoveries in
fact have far greater potential to
improve human lives all in all the
conversations around robots is often
surrounded by panic but along the time
panic isn't a sign of danger and a sign
of panic we could be facing destruction
but we could also be on the brink of an
incredibly positive change that allows
us to focus on our inherent and humanity
to be seen as an inch
and not a handicap well let's go find
out for ourselves
my main focus is going to be the
consumer market here in Japan what is
already accessible for everyday human
beings I don't want to speculate but
rather experience first-hand plan some
pretty rad first-hand research for us to
do first is the robot hotel
[Music]
which was a complete pass this hotel
wasn't exactly what I thought it was
well or what were the side kind of
advertised apparently they had a fire
more than half the robot staff there are
robots at the check-in desk but they
kind of just say the same thing once and
Japanese once in English and then most
of the chicken happens on a tiny little
iPad screen and for the price the rooms
pretty small he's gonna head back to our
B&B next was to attend the robot
restaurant
[Applause]
[Music]
what was I then found this amazing woman
to mow me a TED speaker who discusses
the non romantic relationship she shares
with her robot pepper
whole issue is not about a you know
human controlling the level or I love it
controlling the human or it's nothing to
do with that but it's only about how we
coexist together so we're human daily
creates a blah blah blah blah will
surely advance in his life into the next
level what do you think about that you
agree this was a lot of fun and super
inside let's see you can blink first and
then lastly our interests our own robots
of the day I want to gain access to your
brain like all your knowledge
[Music]
dan dan dan I saw it had a camera and
the ability to take some pretty good
still images and this is what led to the
overarching concepts for the strobe so
we're going to utilize the robot that we
have and we're gonna use that to shoot
in the stop-motion a video that explains
what human beings all about and it's
like a humorous take on on human beings
at the same time we can watch it and be
like oh [ __ ] that's what humans really
are and if you had to look at it from
the side of robots so it's on both sides
together we then use Chen's musical
knowledge to create a soundtrack now
that I had the soundtrack in the bag I
raised him to set up a very basic
stop-motion reek with blackouts duct
tape the tripod glowsticks clamps
scissors a green scrim and local
Japanese magazines and most importantly
with no camera but rather a robot friend
Robo Han that'll be shooting still
images at 12 frames per second
good to go I edited it all together
headed over to shuns place to surprise
him with our video on welcoming robots
to earth shot by a robot hello don't be
alarmed we are humans and we want peace
this is shin and I am down those are our
names every human has
a lot of humans have the same names like
Matt Oh Sara but no one is the same on
the inside you see we have what are
called emotions a very complex set of
chemicals our brain releases which makes
us feel things from happy to sad nobody
likes to be sad but then there's love oh
yes
love it sometimes feels like sadness
because we tend to pre-conceived the
loss of it through the inevitable
understanding that nothing is ever fully
ours or ours forever beds
it's the impermanence of human life that
keeps the flame bright you probably
wouldn't have to worry about any of that
stuff just know that we do it's pretty
stressful being human at times so let it
slip when you get angry you're calling
me names when your parts malfunction
know that it's not you it's most
definitely us dealing with our emotions
it's usually the people that seemed the
least lovable that need the most love
then there's a thing called money which
ultimately controls us all that and
something we call governments which are
a group of humans just like us that sit
around fancy tables and make decisions
that impact the lives of well everyone
it's very complicated you see oh yeah
and one more thing there's a lot of
major endeavors we're gonna need your
help with taking over the human race
isn't one of them don't be a dick thank
you now I just want to say a huge thank
you to my sponsors vnh for the awesome
gear epidemic sound for the insane
library of music and skill share the
online learning platform for creators
it's a link in the description to get a
2 month free trial with Skillshare so
check it out on next week's episode
we're breaking the law in South Africa